we should get it as tough as possible on
these
democrats as a political matter
if it looks like the election is really
going to biden because the democrats are
going to
be merciless when it comes to us they're
not just going to get tough in a
political way they're going to get tough
in a physical way they're
they're threatening republicans all over
you hear joe biden every so often
say we need healing we need unity barack
obama is the first articulate black man
in america he said he said that he did
say that don't forget that he said that
the woke people are going to try to
erase that but he did
the democrats are going to be merciless
well well joe biden is telling us
that we're going to have unity and
healing you have a michigan state
representative
cynthia johnson threatening trump
supporters and telling her constituents
to go after them
so this is just a warning to you
trumpers
be careful walk lightly
we ain't playing with you enough
of the shenanigans
enough is enough
and for those of you who are soldiers
you know how to do it do it right
be in order make them pay
i love you all bye bye
i don't think she loves us all
of all i believe most of what she just
said
the one thing i don't believe is that
she loves us all i think she wants to
kill
trump supporters she's calling
to kill us she's not saying
be mean to them or even maxine waters
said you know
find them where they are in public and
go to their homes and yell at them and
push back on them
this woman is calling on people to
murder us
she says you know you know trumpers you
better watch out you better watch out
and even then you say okay maybe it's
just a sort of
vague threat and she goes those of you
who are soldiers
you know what to do you know how to do
it well what do
soldiers kill people right that's what
they do
soldiers kill people and this elected
democrat wants to kill us
she has been stripped of her committee
assignments and may face
further disciplinary action apparently
according to the michigan house
representative lee chatfield ain't good
enough
buddy not even close to good obviously
she's stripped of her committee
assignments she certainly should be
kicked out of the
michigan state house
i don't know maybe she should face some
criminal charges
you're not allowed to threaten to kill
people
that's a that's a big deal and she's
threatening to kill
all the trump supporters and she's
inciting soldiers to kill us she's
asking the soldiers to kill us
ain't good enough ain't good enough to
strip her of her committee assignments
at the very least she needs to be kicked
out of the the state house
and probably she should face criminal
[Music]
[Music]
charges